the sort of like the Kardashians of the
UK I would say everybody's favorite
Prince Harry got engaged to megan Markel
the actress from suits she's an American
and it's a huge deal because she's
American she's biracial and like oh my
god I'm gonna cry
is that to me to be toast Oh Cheers
definitely wooden chairs that's for sure
no we are the probably the only British
people in the BuzzFeed officer yeah
which means we've been wrangled into
pretending to be experts about the Royal
Family
[Music]
while the royal family doesn't take
duties yeah
the royal family is this group of people
who run the United Kingdom Great Britain
do they run it I think it was pretty
much a bit there the middle ground
between the church and the state
right and the government I thought they
were just like titular their figurehead
they're the embodiment of the British
people right I think it depends how you
phrase the question if you asked us what
our emotional connection and the
importance of the royal family were to
the English people I think we'd have a
great arms fever if you you asked us
kind of like four jobs back it's a
little bit more difficult I mean the
government still run stuff by the Queen
when you come to America a lot of people
kind of ask you how you feel about the
royal family which is an interesting
thing because that's not something I've
really ever thought about we've been
asked about before because it's kind of
like asking how you feel about your own
family
okay Harry William Queen Elizabeth a
second
oh of course little Charlotte and little
Albus Severus the royal family was in
Buckingham Palace
now they live in Kensington Palace is
Kensington or [ __ ] Kensington Palace
is just a palace in Kensington
Buckingham Palace that's of course named
after Lindsey Buckingham for Fleetwood
Mac then will they have homes in a few
places Kate and well living at
Kensington Palace which is inside of
Hyde Park a stone's throw away from them
is Black Moon Palace which is just by
Green Park which is kind of like I would
say like their town house but it's
obviously like a big mansion but the
Queen resides a lot in Scotland it's
like because it's more photogenic like
if you're doing this like taking
pictures it's gonna be like bleep you
know so if they're just like
[Music]
you know what I recognize this woman
from a TV show I think this is Megan
that's Megan from suits America's
favorite TV show suits that's a show
that I think my dad watches I've never
seen it where's that blue blood there's
no way that's her hand it looks like a
Photoshop the hand of somebody else
because she doesn't have to worry a wave
yet that's why I told you the royal wave
is photogenic hello my name is Luis and
I work at BuzzFeed
well well well good evening Xena it's
good dog to you and I cash out and what
do you think is my axis
I don't think America should have a
royal family because I don't want to pay
for it but I do like watching from afar
so I think that the UK should keep doing
what they're doing and
we're gonna not do that here no look at
us we don't pick good families we
already have a royal family it's called
the troops keep calm and carry on blonde
baby Jesus Christ no no one's to marry
me no one huh I don't have this in my
house do you have this in your house
absolutely I'm kind of offended that
these don't have chocolate on top of
them I don't even know if I call this a
teacup honestly I think that most people
like hey so we need to make a royal
family video like what props so we have
popped out on the table normal notice we
did we notice
[Music]